>> Laura: TO RESPOND TO MY
ANKLE, CANDACE OWENS,
COMMUNICATIONS DIRECTOR FOR
TURNING POINT USA P MONICA
CROWLEY, SENIOR COLUMNIST FOR
"THE WASHINGTON TIMES," AND THE
CREDIT STRATEGIST ROCHELLE
RITCHIE.
ARE THESE POLITICAL SWIPES,
REWORKED OLD STORIES, ARE THEY
REALLY WORTH THAT HALF OF THE
REPORTED $65 MILLION ADVANCE
THAT MICHELLE OBAMA WAS PAID BY
CROWN PUBLISHING?
>> TO THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY, THEY
ARE WORTH IT.
THESE ARE THE SAME TIRED AND
BASELESS ACCUSATIONS THAT
EVERYBODY SAYS WHEN THEY WANT TO
SELL BOOKS.
WE SAW THIS FROM MICHAEL WOLF,
WE SAW THIS FROM OMAROSA.
THEY ARE TRYING TO FEED THE
DIVISIVE RHETORIC OUT THERE IN
THE MEDIA.
I TAKE GREAT EXCEPTION TO THE
IDEA THAT OUR PRESIDENT IS A
MISOGYNIST.
MISOGYNY DOES NOT APPOINT SARAH
SANDERS.
MISOGYNY DOES NOT APPOINT
KELLYANNE CONWAY.
EVERYBODY ON HIS STAFF THAT WE
ARE SEEING BEING LED BY WOMEN.
IT'S RIDICULOUS, IT'S REALLY
UNBECOMING, ESPECIALLY COMING
FROM A FORMER ADMINISTRATION TOO
COSTLY VERBALLY ASSAULTED AS
PRESIDENT.
>> Laura: ROCHELLE, IT'S
INTERESTING COMING FROM SOMEBODY
WHO'S SUCH A GLOBAL CELEBRITY AS
MICHELLE OBAMA TO HEAR HER
SOUND -- I WOULD SAY RATHER
ORDINARY IN HER CRITICISM OF THE
PRESIDENT.
WHAT SHE SAID ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT WITHOUT NECESSARILY
MENTIONING HIS NAME IS WHAT YOU
WOULD HEAR, YOU KNOW, ONE OF THE
OTHER CABLE NETWORKS -- MORNING,
NOON, NIGHT, YOU COULD PICK THAT
OUT OF THE COMMENTARY YOU HEAR
ALL THE TRUMP HATERS ON THE
OTHER CABLE.
HOW DOES THAT DISTINGUISH
MICHELLE OBAMA FROM ANY
GARDEN-VARIETY LEFTIST?
>> LOOK, LAURA, IT'S NOT
SURPRISED THAT I'M THE ONLY
PERSON ON THE PANEL WHO'S
ACTUALLY EXCITED TO BE
MICHELLE OBAMA'S BOOK.
I THINK SHE'S AN EXCEPTIONAL
WOMAN.
I THINK SHE SERVES AS A GREAT
EXAMPLE TO WOMEN ALL ACROSS THE
WORLD THAT OUR TICKET TO SUCCESS
IS OUR BRAINS AND NOT OUR BODY.
I THINK SHE'S SIMPLY TELLING HER
TRUTH.
I MEAN, THE XENOPHOBIC
ACCUSATIONS THAT WERE HURLED AT
HER HUSBAND WERE DEFINITELY
OFFENSIVE AND SHE MENTIONED IN
HER BOOK IT BUT HER FAMILY AT
RISK.
I THINK SHE'S JUST BEING VERY
CANDID AND VERY HONEST.
THIS IS ONE PORTION OF THE BOOK
SHE IS TALKING ABOUT TRUMP.
IT'S NOT ENTIRELY ABOUT TRUMP.
I DON'T SEE REALLY THE PROBLEM
WITH HER WRITING THIS BOOK AND I
THINK MANY MORE FIRST LADIES,
I'M SURE FIRST LADY MELANIA
TRUMP WILL COME OUT WITH A BOOK
AND SHE'LL SHARE HER PERSONAL
FEELINGS WHAT IT'S LIKE TO BE IN
A TRUMP WHITE HOUSE.
I'M NOT REALLY SURE WHY THERE IS
SO MUCH ANGER AND HATRED AS FAR
AS MICHELLE OBAMA COMING OUT AND
SHARING HER TRUTH.
>> Laura: IT'S NOT ANGER.
IT'S REALLY NOT HATRED.
WE HAVE NOTHING PERSONALLY
AGAINST THE FIRST LADY AND SHE'S
EXTREMELY IMPRESSIVE AS AN
INDIVIDUAL, AS A MOTHER, AS A
SPOKESPERSON FOR WHAT SHE
BELIEVES IN.
I THINK SHE'S VERY IMPRESSIVE.
WE ARE TALKING SOMETHING THAT
THEY DECIDED TO SELL THIS BOOK
WITH.
TRUMP TRASHING IS A CASH IN
SCENARIO, MONICA.
WHEN YOU TRASH TRUMP -- YOU CAN
SAY THE SAME THING ABOUT PEOPLE
CRITICIZING OBAMA EARLY ON IN
THE PRESIDENCY, TO BE FAIR HERE.
BUT YOU TRASH TRUMP, YOU GET A
BIG ADVANCE.
WHY IS THAT INTERESTING?
THAT'S MY POINT THAT IT'S
INTERESTING TO HEAR ABOUT HER
GROWING UP.
I GUESS MAYBE HOW SHE MET
BARACK, BUT WE'VE HEARD THOSE
STORIES BEFORE.
BUT TRUMP IS A RACIST, TRUMP IS
A MISOGYNIST -- OKAY.
WE'VE BEEN HEARING THAT NOW FOR
YEARS.
>> RIGHT.
IT'S BORING AND PREDICTABLE,
THAT'S DISAPPOINTING TO HEAR IT
FROM THE FORMER FIRST LADY.
THERE USED TO BE A RULE, IF YOU
DON'T HAVE SOMETHING NICE TO SAY
ABOUT SOMEONE DON'T SAY ANYTHING
AT ALL.
FORMER PRESIDENTS, THEIR WIVES,
OTHERS IN A PRESIDENT'S INNER
CIRCLE, MR. OBAMA WAS
PREDECESSORS HAVE ABIDED BY THAT
RULE BUT MR. PRESIDENT AND THE
FIRST LADY HAS, I WONDER IF SHE
HAS POLITICAL AMBITIONS OF HER
OWN, WHAT SHE CAN STAKE OUT THIS
ROUND IN ATTACKING THE PRESIDEN
PRESIDENT.
I ALSO THINK BOTH OF THEM WERE
SO CONCERNED WHEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS ELECTED THAT
THEIR ENTIRE LEGACY WAS ABOUT TO
GO OUT THE WINDOW.
WE WERE TOLD FOR EIGHT YEARS BY
THE OBAMAS AND EVERYONE IN THEIR
ADMINISTRATION WAS THAT THE NEW
LOCAL WAS -- AMERICAN DECLINE,
THE GLOBALIST MARCH, ALL THESE
THINGS WERE INEVITABLE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAVE PUT THE
LIVES TO ALL THAT.
WHAT YOU ARE SEEING IS ENORMOUS
FRUSTRATION AND LASHING OUT ON
THE PART OF MRS. OBAMA AND
FRANKLY EVERYONE IN THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
>> Laura: I WANT TO PLAY FOR
YOU SOMETHING FROM'S OR LENA
ZERLINA
MAXWELL AND SHE WAS ON MSNBC ON
THE SUBJECT.
>> I AGREE WITH HER.
THE FACT WE ELECTED SOMEONE WHO
HAD NO QUALIFICATIONS TO BE A
PRESIDENT WHO WAS RUNNING
AGAINST A WOMAN WITH A LAUNDRY
LIST OF QUALIFICATIONS TO BE
PRESIDENT AND INSTEAD AMERICA OR
THE ELECTORATE CHOSE TO GAVE THE
ELECTORAL COLLEGE TO THE PERSON
WITH NO EXPERIENCE WHO HAPPENED
TO BE A MAN LIKE ALL THE OTHER
PRESIDENTS.
WHEN MICHELLE OBAMA IS
HIGHLIGHTING THAT THAT IN IT OF
ITSELF IS MISOGYNISTIC AND
SEXIST AND PERHAPS AS A COUNTRY
WE SHOULD TAKE A MOMENT TO
REFLECT ON THAT.
>> Laura: AGAIN FROM A WOMAN
WHO VOTED FOR TRUMP ARE EITHER
DUMB OR THEY ARE JUST FOLLOWING
THEIR HUSBANDS OR WE ARE NOT
GOING TO OFFER ANY IDEAS,
CANDACE OWENS DOWN MY, HOW TO
RAISE THE STANDARD OF LIVING FOR
THE
STANDARD AMERICAN, WE ARE GOINGT
STANDARD AMERICAN, WE ARE GOINGO
STANDARD AMERICAN, WE ARE GOINGC
STANDARD AMERICAN, WE ARE GOINGL
PEOPLE MISOGYNIST, RACIST,
XENOPHOBIC, NATIVIST, ALL THE
ISTS AND ISMS, THEY ARE ALL WORN
OUT, FORGET DEBATING IDEAS.
>> YOU'RE RIGHT.
IT IS FRUSTRATION, FATIGUE, NOT
OFFERING ANYTHING OF SUBSTANCE.
NO IDEOLOGICAL DEBATE TAKING
PLACE BUT IT'S BEEN PROVEN NOW,
OKAY, YOU ARE APPREHENSIVE IN
THE BEGINNING FOR TRUMP AND HIS
LACK OF EXPERIENCE IN THE REALM
OF -- DOES NOT PROVE THAT THIS
PRESIDENT IS TREMENDOUSLY
SUCCESSFUL.
IT FEELS A BIT LIKE WHINING.
AS AMERICANS, WE ARE READY TO
MOVE ON THAT EVERYBODY HAS TO
BE -- YOU DO NOT ELECT SOMEBODY
BECAUSE THEY ARE A WOMAN.
YOU SELECT SOMEBODY BECAUSE THEY
ARE BEST SUITED FOR THE JOB.
UP AGAINST HILLARY CLINTON, HE
RAN A BETTER CAMPAIGN AND THAT'S
WHY HE'S IN THE OVAL OFFICE
TODAY.
>> Laura: ROCHELLE, DO YOU
THINK THE PRESS HAS TREATED
MELANIA IN THE SAME WAY THAT
THEY TREATED MICHELLE?
>> LOOK, NO.
I DON'T THINK THEY HAVE AND I
CAN BE HONEST ABOUT THAT.
WHEN WE LOOK AT HOW
MICHELLE OBAMA WAS TREATED, SHE
WAS TREATED IN A VERY DIFFERENT
WAY, BUT I THINK THAT'S BECAUSE
HER HUSBAND WAS ALSO NOT PUSHING
FORWARD A VERY DIVISIVE RHETORIC
IN THE PRESS AND HER HUSBAND WAS
NOT ATTACKING THE PRESS.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT -- YOU
KNOW, MELANIA IS NOT INNOCENT
WHEN IT COMES TO THIS WHOLE
BIRTHER ISSUE WHICH SHE PEDALED
WITH HER HUSBAND.
THEY HAVE NOT TREATED HER
FAIRLY, BUT AT THE SAME TIME
THEY ARE LOOKING AT THE
ADMINISTRATION, THE RHETORIC
THAT IS COMING FROM HER HUSBAND.
IT'S NOT ATTRACTIVE TO THEM.
>> Laura: ARE YOU AWARE OF THE
POLLS AT THE END OF THE OBAMA
EVISCERATION THAT HIS OFFICE HAD
UNITED THE COUNTRY, ARE YOU
AWARE OF THOSE, ROCHELLE?
>> WHAT I'M AWARE OF 77% OF THE
COUNTRY IN THE POLLS THAT CAME
OUT BEFORE THE MIDTERM ELECTIONS
AS THE COUNTRY FEELS THAT THEY
ARE MORE DIVISIVE.
I AM AWARE OF THAT POLL.
>> Laura: WHAT I'M TRYING TO
SAY, AND MONICA I'M SURE YOU'RE
AWARE OF THIS, THAT THERE WAS A
WILD PERCENTAGE OF AMERICANS WHO
BELIEVE THAT THE OBAMA
PRESIDENCY WAS NOT A UNITING
FORCE IN AMERICA, DESPITE ALL
THE PROMISE AND HISTORIC NATURE
OF HIS PRESIDENCY, PEOPLE FELT
LIKE THE COUNTRY WAS MORE
DIVIDED AND LESS UNITED --
VEHICLE
HOW?
>> Laura: AND ANGRIER.
THIS IS NOT A DAILY CALLER POLL.
THIS -- FORGIVE ME FOR NOT
HAVING IT OFF THE TOP OF MY
HEAD, I DID IT EARLY ON RADIO.
NOT HOW A LOT OF PEOPLE FELT AT
THE END OF EIGHT YEARS OF OBAMA,
WHY IMPART THEY ELECTED TRUMP.
>> THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
WHAT WE SAW OVER THE EIGHT YEARS
WITH PRESIDENT OBAMA IS WHILE HE
WAS PERSONALLY POPULAR, PEOPLE
APPRECIATED THE FACT THAT HE WAS
AN EXCEPTIONAL CHARACTER, THE
FIRST AFRICAN-AMERICAN PRESIDENT
AND THEY WERE A CROWD OF THAT
FACT.
HIS POLICIES WERE HOLY
UNPOPULAR.
IN SOME WAYS THAT'S THE MIRROR
IMAGE, PERSONALLY NOT SO POPULAR
BUT HIS POLICIES ARE INCREDIBLY
POPULAR.
BUT GETTING BACK TO THE MELANIA
ISSUE, ANY REPUBLICAN FIRST LADY
IS GOING TO BE TREATED LIKE
THIS, LARA.
IT'S A FACT OF THE DOUBLE
STANDARD LIFE IN AMERICA,
UNFORTUNATELY.
IT'S REALLY UNFAIR TO HER.
I THINK AMERICANS BY AND LARGE
ARE SICK OF THE DOUBLE STANDARD.
>> Laura: IT'S APPARENT.
>> HE'S TRYING TO SMASH IT.
WE ARE OUT OF TIME, BUT THE
BUSHES DID NOT CRITICIZE THE
OBAMAS.
THEY DIDN'T.
>> THAT'S CORRECT.
>> WHY WOULD THEY!
I KNOW YOU'RE TALKING TO CANDACE
CANDACE.
>> Laura: BECAUSE WE HAD
BENGHAZI, --
>> THEY ALSO DIDN'T QUESTION
WHETHER OR NOT OBAMA WAS BORN IN
THIS COUNTRY.
>> THESE ARE CHEAP SHOTS.
>> I'M GOING TO FINISH MY
THOUGHT.